it is time for drew's news if news
programs were sensations we'd be that
feeling you get when you pull off your
pantyhose
with me at the desk he's got legs and he
knows how to use them rossi ross
matthews
well first up today in our news vogues
may cover girl the stunning mom-to-be
rihanna that's right
when she got pregnant rihanna says that
she knew one thing
she'd never see a maternity aisle
because she loves to dress up she talks
about the father of the baby her partner
asap rocky and she says she doesn't want
guys out of the friend zone easy
and she's known him for a decade but
everything changed over the pandemic
when they took a road trip just the two
of them across the country in a tour bus
oh god she's not sure if she's having a
baby shower but if she does it'll be
co-ed with cocktails she says she wants
people to leave plastered and crawling
out yes god she is everything everything
rihanna
there's so much there's so much to break
down one i want to go to that baby
shower and get drunk
two
interesting that they were friends and
got out of the friend zone she doesn't
want to wear maternity clothes all i
want to wear is maturity clothes that
stuff looks soak elastic jeans sign me
up
our next story comes from the knot
that's right we've got their cover boy
for their summer issue right here and
it's our very own ross matthews
[Applause]
now
this is
obviously ross and that is wellington
ross's fiancee and guess who's actually
here today welly hi
oh my valley's here
come join us
[Applause]
look at my what you guys hear me talk
about him all the time
speaking of ah
harry styles is set to hit the coachella
stage again this next weekend because he
already nailed it
this past weekend marie claire reports
that harry brought out a surprise guest
pop icon shania twain and they both
crushed that
in head to toe sequins they said they
sang man i feel like a woman which is a
great title because it includes
everybody and harry revealed that he
listened to so much shania with his mom
in the car growing up he says that
shania taught him how to sing
gave him amazing memories with his mom
and also taught him men are trash
perry's album coming out called harry's
house is uh about to drop but his first
single has already broken records as it
got 16 million streams in its first 24
hours on spotify
yeah yeah
i think i think i was responsible for
like a million of those
we've got a dilemma that we found on
reddit i thought this was actually
really interesting this was discussed on
elvis duran's morning show who i love
hey elvis if you're out there um what do
you do if your sister is planning to
name your future nephew their child
after an actual crime one woman wrote
that she's feuding with her sister after
criticizing her name choice of arson
which is a ripoff of fire starter fire
starter yes
hello my kid my kid harper goes to
school but the real names are like yale
captain like real interesting names that
i never had so those are kind of just
cool and different but when it gets into
crimes i don't love it as much uh i know
my son's name is poison pete but that's
a whole other story
[Music]
you